JULIE WISKIRCHEN: Good
afternoon everybody.
I'm Julie Wiskirchen from the
Authors@Google team in Los Angeles.
And today, we are welcoming
William Knoedelseder, who's
going to be discussing his new
book, "Bitter Brew-- the Rise
and Fall of Anheuser-Busch and
Americas King of Beers."
I grew up in St. Louis.
It's the home of
Anheuser-Busch.
And I think I was in high school
when I finally realized
there was other beer besides
Budweiser in the world.
So the Busch family are
almost like the
Kennedys in St. Louis.
It's quite a dynasty.
So I'm very interested to hear
some of the backstory behind
it all today.
And just a little background on
Bill-- he spent 12 years as
a reporter at the "LA Times"
where his groundbreaking
coverage of the recording
industry for the newspaper's
financial section
resulted in the
critically-acclaimed book "Stiffed--
A True Story of MCA, the Music
Business, and the Mafia."
He's also been a television
executive creating, managing,
and producing news programs for
Knight Ridder, Fox, and
the USA Network.
At USA, he was vice
president of news.
His last book, "I'm
Dying Up Here--
Heartbreak and High Times in
Stand-Up Comedy's Golden Era,"
has been optioned for
film by Jim Carrey.
And today, he's going to talk
about "Bitter Brew." So please
join me in welcoming William
Knoedelseder.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Hi everyone.
For anybody who's wondering,
my name in German is
pronounced "Kenerdelzader."
It means noodle cooker or
dumpling maker.
So those are my roots.
I'm also Irish on my
mother's side.
So I'm a combination or
Irish and German--
I think maybe an expert on beer
on the day of my birth.
It's actually very charming
that they're serving
beer for you today.
Not a lot of companies give you
free beer in the middle of
the day while you're working,
and on a Monday.
As it turns out though,
it's actually kind of
an old-school thing.
Because Anheuser-Busch used to
do that back in the day.
In the 1890s, when the brewery
employees worked from 4:00 AM
to 7:00 PM seven days a week,
just like you guys, they
served them beer.
They eventually bargained to get
three hours off on Sunday
so that they could
go to church.
And they were paid between
$50 and $75 a
month and 20 free beers--
not a month, a day.
They got 20 free beers
a day every day.
I've done the math.
That's 140 beers a
week, 602 beers a
month, and 7,300 a year--
while you're working
in a plant.
That's what a good union
can do for you I guess.
"Bitter Brew" is the story of
America's most successful beer
company, and the colorful and
often outrageous family that
founded it and operated it
for about 150 years--
from three days after Lincoln
was first inaugurated to the
week that Obama was
first elected.
And that takes in a
lot of history.
That's the Industrial
Revolution, the Civil War,
World War I, Prohibition, World
War II, not to mention
the Budweiser frogs campaign
and what's up.
So it's also the story of beer
in America and how you came to
be drinking the style
and brand of beer
you're drinking now.
And again, in addition
to that, it's
a story of my hometown.
Because I grew up
in St. Louis.
And like Julie, I was steeped
in the lore of Budweiser and
the Clydesdales and Cardinals
baseball and the Busch family,
who were the royalty
of the city.
And she mentioned
the Kennedy's.
They're very much like that,
especially the Busch males.
They exhibited all the
recklessness and sexual
rapacity of the Kennedy's
without the appetite for
public service.
They were very wealthy and
privileged, but they weren't
pretentious.
They were boisterous, hard
drinking, fast driving, gun
loving, skirt chasing
bad boys.
And they seemed to get away with
everything, which I think
is why my high school buddies
and college buddies and I
thought they were so cool.
Because it's all this, and they
own a beer company, too,
back in the time.
In fact, in my high school
yearbook my senior year, the
graduating seniors were all
asked to state what their
ambition was.
And I'm kind of embarrassed to
report that under my picture
in my senior yearbook, it says,
president of Budweiser.
It's weird now.
And I went on to the University
of Missouri where I
majored in Budweiser, which
was a special decelerated
seven-year undergraduate
program.
And in the '80s, when I came out
here to be a writer in Los
Angeles, early on
I had this idea.
And I wrote up a proposal for a
television series based on a
fictional family that owned
a baseball team and a
brewery in St. Louis.
And I took it around.
And at the time, "Dallas" was
the number one show on
television.
And there was another show
called "Falcon Crest," which
was about a rich family that
owned a winery in Napa.
So I thought, this
is a sure thing.
But nobody was interested
in my thing.
And I remember one big time
agent with this very
intimidating name-- he was like
the number one literary
agent around.
And he had this name.
His name was Sterling Lord.
And Sterling Lord told me
bluntly that not only was beer
and baseball in St. Louis not
nearly as sexy as oil tycoons
in Dallas, but my proposal
wasn't very well written.
So I either improved in my
writing, or Hollywood
standards have gone down.
Because right now, "Bitter Brew"
is being developed as a
TV series by Lionsgate
Television.
And alas, Mr. Lord will not
be around to see it,
God rest his soul.
But I'll never forget
him for that.
The Anheuser-Busch story, the
brewery story and the family,
starts in 1857 when Adolphus
Busch, an 18-year-old
immigrant from Mainz, Germany,
stepped off a
steamboat in St. Louis.
And he basically inhaled the
aroma of the 40 or so
breweries that were operating
there at the time.
He was part of a mass influx
of Europeans--
7 and 1/2 million of them--
that arrived between
1820 and 1870.
They basically doubled the
population of the country.
And 2/3 of them, as it turns
out, were from Germany and
Ireland, which were
beer-drinking countries.
The Irish, of course, were
fleeing poverty and famine in
their country.
So they pretty much arrived
starving and penniless.
And they had to fight their way,
literally block by block,
into New York.
The Germans tended to be middle
class merchants who
were looking for a more
democratic form of government
after they'd had a
liberal political
revolution fail in Germany.
So they arrived with some
money in their pockets.
And instead of going into New
York, they traveled to the
interior of the country.
And they came down the
major waterways.
And a huge number of them
settled in an area that became
known as the German Triangle.
And the points of the triangle
were Cincinnati, Milwaukee,
and St. Louis.
St. Louis was a particularly
good place for a brewery, to
build breweries, because number
one, it was situated on
the Mississippi River.
So there was this great
free supply of water.
And it was also built on
a series of very large
underground caves.
So they could store the
beer and keep it cool.
There was no refrigeration
back then.
One other important thing--
the Germans and the
Irish preferred a
different kind of beer.
Like the English who colonized
the country, the Irish
preferred strong tasting ales
that were made with a yeast
that floated to the top
during fermentation.
And the Germans, they liked a
different kind of beer, a
crisper, lighter tasting beer
that was made with a yeast
that sunk to the bottom.
And it's called lager, because
that's the word for aging.
And this kind of beer takes at
least a month of aging-- at
least that's what they thought
back then-- to achieve its
full taste potential.
So there was two different
competing
styles of beer there.
And of course, the Germans
would eventually win out,
because they tend to
take over things.
And every place they settled,
of course, they built
breweries, the Germans.
Because there was just these
tons and tons of Germans
pouring in, and they
had to be serviced.
They had a big thirst
for beer.
That was their drink.
It was not the American drink.
We were not a beer
drinking country.
The Germans sort
of made it so.
And when Adolphus Busch arrived
in St. Louis, all of
the beer that was made
in St. Louis was
consumed in St. Louis.
And it was like 18 million
$0.05 glasses a year.
Every brewery was a local-- it
was a hyper-local business.
You sold in the neighborhood.
Every brewery was
a microbrewery.
Their names were invariably the
name of the street they
were on, the neighborhood they
were located in, or the
founding family.
And the names of the founding
families are funny if you read
them today.
The list is like, Brinkworth,
Breizedick, Feurerbacher,
Hyderbreeder, Klausman,
Schlostein, Schlops, Schners,
Stump, Stifle, Urich,
Vinkelmeyer.
There were like 200 breweries
in Missouri at
one point early on.
Because every city had the
same thing going on.
And the only name that you'd
look at today, the list-- and
I've seen the list-- the only
one you would recognize is
Anheuser-Busch.
The rest of them have
all gone away.
And every now and then, you
would see one Irish brewery--
Mullally or Mullanthy or
something like that.
But it was pretty much a German
thing by the turn of
the century.
And Adolphus was a really
smart, young guy.
After a couple of years of
operating his own beer supply
business, he married the
daughter of one of his
customers who was a very wealthy
soap manufacture named
Eberhard Anheuser, who had come
into reluctant ownership
of a failing brewery because
of a bad debt.
He didn't want to own it.
He took it over because they
didn't pay the bill.
And it was called a Bavarian
brewery, and it made beer so
bad that the bartenders were
used to people spitting it
back across the bar at
them all the time.
And of course, they weren't
doing well.
And Adolphus convinced his
father-in-law to let him run
the business--
manage it anyway.
And one of the first smart
things he did was, he acquired
a recipe for a light tasting
lager beer that had been made
for years by some monks in the
bohemian village of Budweis.
And it was known in the
region as Budweiser--
"Budveiser," I'm sorry.
And ever since that happened,
there's been lawsuits between
Anheuser-Busch and the
people over there.
And it's gone on
for 100 years.
And I'm always asked at these
things, well, why didn't you
include that in the book?
And why didn't you
go into that?
And the reason is simple--
because it's so boring.
The controversy is that he
clearly paid the monks for the
recipe, he brought it back here,
changed it, and no one
ever expected Anheuser-Busch to
get that big and sell beer
all over the world.
And they've gone back and
forth with the lawsuits.
One side wins, the other
side wins, they appeal,
it goes on and on.
It's just stupendously boring.
And it hasn't resulted
in anything yet.
It's still the same.
Budweiser never tasted the
same as "Budveiser."
Because they changed it to
make it more palatable to
American tastes.
I've had both, and they
really don't resemble
one another at all.
But the Budvar people, they
still resent this.
And they may have a case.
It's just not a very interesting
story to tell, so
I didn't go into it.
The second really smart thing
that Adolphus did was, he
became the first brewery in the
United States, and maybe
the world, to pasteurize and
bottle his beer so it could be
shipped outside the city limits,
even outside the
state, without spoiling.
And that changed everything.
He was really more of an
industrialist than a brewery.
He didn't much like beer.
He preferred wine.
And he was a proponent of
vertical integration before
there was a name for it.
To fire his brewery, he bought
a couple coal mines on the
other side of the river and then
built a railway to bring
the coal into the plant.
He bought into the bottling
company that
his beer went into.
And he bought into the rail car
company that made the cars
that took the beer to market.
And in the end, he controlled
it all the way to the end,
because he bought into the
saloons that would sell it.
What he would do
is, he would--
he sort of pioneered this.
He would pay for a proprietor's
alcohol license,
all his licenses, his glassware,
his signage, pay
his rent for a few months, and
he'd set them up in business
with a signed agreement that
they would only sell
Anheuser-Busch beer,
his products.
So he was just killing
the competition.
They all had to sort of
do the same thing.
They had to then go out and
get their own saloons, and
have them sell their
beer exclusively.
And this eventually came
back to bite them all.
Because the proprietors--
their partners would
run brothels out
of their back room.
And they would pay off the
politicians and the cops to
look the other way.
And this would have
repercussions for them, and
I'll explain to you
in a minute.
Adolphus was right.
He believed that beer
was going to become
the national drink.
And it did turn out that way,
and not just beer, but
specifically lager beer.
And by the time he died in 1913,
I think the per capita
consumption of beer
had quadrupled.
And America surpassed Germany
as the number one beer
producing country
in the world.
It was our 17th largest
industry.
And then, something totally
crazy happened.
Under pressure from a strident
Christian minority--
imagine that--
Congress and the state
legislatures all across the
country passed and ratified
the Eighteenth Amendment,
which outlawed the sale of
alcoholic beverages.
And they literally outlawed
their 17th largest industry.
And the repercussions were
just huge in business.
There were 1,300 breweries
operating
in the United States.
All of those people pretty much
lost their jobs overnight.
And anybody who supplied the
beer business with anything,
they lost their jobs--
the bottlers, the people who
made the wooden kegs, the
coopers, the railroads
lost money--
anybody that had anything
to do with that.
I read somewhere in
my research--
on the internet, so therefore
it must be true--
that New York and Boston at the
time relied on the federal
excise tax on alcohol for
85% of their income.
So it was a pretty radical thing
to do to all of a sudden
not be able to do that.
And in St. Louis, it caused the
loss of 40,000 jobs in a
relatively small city--
brewery-related jobs.
And the number nationwide--
brewery-related--
was something like
1.2 million.
And that doesn't include the
number of people in the
distilled spirits business,
which is just as labor
intensive as brewing.
The irony is that it was the
distillers that were first
targeted by the temperance
movement.
They weren't after beer.
They were after the
whiskey makers.
And for years leading up to
Prohibition, the brewers tried
really hard to distinguish
themselves between themselves
and the distillers who were
their competitor for the
consumer's advertising dollar.
And they would push themselves
as an invigorating,
non-intoxicating,
wholesome drink.
And Anheuser-Busch had a
magazine ad or a newspaper ad
that said something stupid
like, Budweiser--
spells temperance.
OK, right.
But the funny thing was, the
Germans kind of believed that.
They historically felt that
their product was sort of
healthy and wholesome.
And the way they drank was
different than the way, say,
the Irish did.
In St. Louis, the Irish bars--
there were no women
in those bars.
It was guys getting smashed
before or after work, or
during the day, or
whatever else.
And they went in there
to get loaded.
The Germans, when they came,
they brought with them the
whole idea of beer halls
and beer gardens.
And they would drink with
the whole family.
The kids would be there.
It was sort of a family thing,
and everybody got together and
sang crazy German songs.
And it was kind of wholesome
compared to your basic Irish
or English pub.
Anyway, so the anti-alcohol
forces sort of bought the
whole wholesome thing
for a while.
They weren't really going after
the brewers until they
figured out that, wait a minute,
most of these saloons
that are serving this devil
whiskey that's killing
America's soul are owned
by brewers--
not just brewers, but
Germans, foreigners.
And the biggest, baddest foreign
brewer of all was
Adolphus Busch.
So he became the poster boy for
the anti-alcohol movement.
He didn't live to see
prohibition pass, but shortly
before he died, he made the
pronouncement that if it did
pass, it would, quote, "ruin
the whole world,"
which it didn't do.
But anyway, his son, who was
named August Anheuser Busch,
managed to keep the company
operating during Prohibition
by pivoting and manufacturing
related products that were the
result of Adolphus' vertical
integration.
He manufactured railcars.
He manufactured refrigeration
stuff.
He manufactured ice cream.
He made a malt-based soft
drink called Bevo.
And they had a nonalcoholic
version of Budweiser.
And the most important thing,
the most profitably thing they
did, was they established a
baking division, which sold
barley malt syrup and yeast,
and became really
successful at that.
And they called it the baking
division when in fact it was
coincidentally branded
Budweiser Products.
And those two ingredients were
the key ingredients in the
booming home brewery
trade in the
country, which was illegal.
So they went from being the most
successful brewery to the
most successful bootleg
warehouse, bootleg operation,
in the country.
And that's how they
kept the company
running through Probation.
They kept 2,000 people employed
when St. Louis had
unemployment 30%.
And that's when the city just
always remembered August
Anheuser Busch for that, because
he did keep it open.
And what happened then--
so Probation lasts 13 years.
And when Franklin Roosevelt ran
for president, he ran on
an anti-Prohibition thing.
And in February, 1933, shortly
after he was inaugurated, he
was eager to get
people working.
So he urged Congress to
immediately put beer--
3.2% alcohol--
back on sale in the United
States, which was eight months
ahead of the repeal
of Prohibition.
Because to appeal Prohibition,
they had to ratify a new
amendment to the Constitution.
And it was going to take eight
months while all the stays
went through.
But they put beer back on
the market right away.
And in exchange for that favor
he did for them, he puts some
new regulations on the industry
where the brewers
could no longer own an
interest in retail
establishments.
From then on, and to this day,
they had to sell their beer in
arm's length transactions with
middlemen, who were the
distributors, and then they
dealt with the retailers.
And that was to keep the
corruption out of it.
The night that beer went on
sale, at midnight on April 7,
1933, a crowd of 35,000 people
gathered outside the gates of
Anheuser-Busch's brewery.
And they saying "Happy Days
are Here Again." And they
counted down the clock for
the gates to open up.
And it did.
It was quite an amazing scene.
The gates opened up, and 1,200
trucks full of beer just
rolled out of the gates to make
deliveries all over town.
And by dawn, the citizens
of St. Louis had
consumed every drop.
There was nothing left.
And supposedly, that scene
happened in other big brewing
cities in the country.
There was four or
five of them.
And today, economists are sort
of in agreement that April
1933 marked the end of
the Great Recession.
That's when the economy started
expanding again.
And it did really well for--
the night that Prohibition
[INAUDIBLE], they literally
had a brass band out in front.
And the whole city went crazy.
But anyway, they pretty much
agree that April '33 was the
end of the Depression.
And beer sales soared.
And the economy was on
an uptick for the
next couple of years.
Unemployment dropped by half,
and everything was going fine.
Then all of a sudden, the
economy hit a tailspin.
And unemployment shot back up.
And the reason was, there was
a confluence of factors that
sound really familiar today.
The Roosevelt administration
tried to cut the deficit by
slashing government spending,
Congress voted a tax hike on
the rich, and the Federal
Reserve sort of tightened
their money policy.
And that produced what
is known as the Great
Recession of 1937.
And by this time, Adolphus is
gone, his son August Anheuser
Busch is gone, and the guy in
charge of the brewer is the
third generation.
He's Adolphus' grandson, August
Anheuser Busch II,
forever known as Gussie.
And Gussie was the guy
who really put the
company on the map.
But he was in charge in 1937.
And his reaction to this
downturn in the economy viewed
from this age of egregious
corporate greed is really
extraordinary, I think.
And I was sort of surprised
when I found this.
I'll read this to you.
"The company announced that it
was going to devote the entire
1938 advertising budget to
a series of newspaper and
magazine ads aimed at calming
the nation's economic fears
and restoring confidence in the
ability of the country's
institution to deal
with the problems.
The idea was to, quote, 'sell
America to Americans,'
according to a statement
Anheuser-Busch sent to its
employees and the industry
at large.
'Our challenge is more important
than selling beer,
more important than making
profits,' the statement said.
The ads contained no pictures
of the product, no statement
about its merits.
Instead, they offered patriotic
pep talks that might
have made Ronald Reagan blush.
'Each sunrise in America ushers
in new opportunities to
those who keep their chins up,
who never lose that lusty
courage and willingness that
made ours the most envied
nation on earth,' said one.
'Confidence sailed our pioneer
forefathers across the
turbulent Atlantic," said
another. 'Confidence helped
our grandfathers extend the
stubborn frontier, and made
ours the strongest and most
abundant land on Earth.
Confidence is now ready to take
America further still.'"
The only mention of Budweiser in
the ads for the whole year
came at the end.
There was a tag line that said,
"Live life, every golden
minute of it.
Drink Budweiser, every gold
drop of it." And without
question, there was self
interest behind the ads.
Gussie figured that confident
wage-earning men were likely
to drink more beer than fearful
unemployed men.
But the campaign wasn't
a cynical ploy.
Gussie believed in his gut that
serving the public good
also served the company, and
that goodwill was always the
best salesman.
It all went back to the
beginning, when he told his
step father, Eberhard Anheuser,
his new partner--
he told him, our businesses
isn't making beer.
Our business is making
friends.
And Gussie believed that
till the day he died.
He said that almost every
day at some point.
He came to the conclusion that
the company would never go
wrong by doubling down
on patriotism
and the public good.
And this was the quote that
struck me when I found it.
He said, "If we do something in
the public interest, which
at the same time is profitable
to the company, then this is
indeed very good business." And
as it turned out, at the
end of this year that they had
where they didn't do any
advertising except these
patriotic things, the industry
increased by 26%.
And Budweiser sales
went up 176%.
And for the next 30,
I don't know, 37--
something like that-- years
with Gussie at the helm,
Anheuser-Busch sold more--
except for a couple
years in between--
they sold more than any
brewer on the planet.
And when I was doing this book,
Gussie was like a gift
from the gods.
He's such an amazing character,
and such an
indelible figure in
American commerce.
He was the quintessential
robber baron.
He was blunt and coarse and
impatient and vindictive and
hot tempered and spoiled.
And he was irascible.
And yet, he was also charming
and charismatic and
sentimental.
And he was a guy with unbridled
appetites who ate
life in huge big bites.
And he was the greatest beer
salesman who ever lived.
He was made to do this.
He was married four
times, cheated on
his first three wives.
We don't know about the fourth
because he was in his 80s.
What's cheating when
you're 83?
I don't know.
He had 11 children
during that time.
And he raised them, in the words
of one of his daughters
who's still living-- and she
told me, daddy raised us with
a great deal of love
and anger.
[INAUDIBLE].
And he was the guy who
introduced Clydesdales to
America, which is really kind
of an amazing thing if you
think about it.
Before he hitched Clydesdales
up to those bright red beer
wagons, they were just
mud-splattered farm animals.
They were draft horses that were
used primarily to haul
coal and lumber.
But he had this abiding passion
for these animals.
And he saw this as a way
to promote beer.
But he didn't just use
them to promote beer.
He took over the breeding of
Clydesdales in this country.
He improved the breed.
He coddled them.
He took care of them.
And he made them into
something more.
He made them heroic.
If you see the stables that they
were kept in his estate,
a stall for a Clydesdale--
I mean, Clydesdales,
they're huge.
I don't know if you've ever been
up close to one, but they
are really big.
And some of them weigh
2,000 pounds.
So a stall for a Clydesdale is
about as big as that area of
the room right there.
And there are apartments in
Manhattan that cost $3,000 a
month that are smaller and not
as nice as a Clydesdale stall.
So he really did something
for them.
And it's a big thing.
He made them the most beloved
breed in the world, possibly,
and certainly one of the
most recognizable.
He's also the guy that married
beer and baseball, which paved
the way for Anheuser-Busch to
eventually become synonymous
with American sport.
And he sort of foresaw that,
although in the beginning,
when he bought the team, the
Cardinals, in 1953, he saw it
as an opportunity to own a
giant tavern where 30,000
people would sit in the
sweltering St. Louis heat with
nothing to slake their thirst
except Budweiser.
This was just too good.
So that's what he did.
And then what happened was,
after he became a baseball
team owner in addition to being
a brewer, he became a
national celebrity.
Reporters all over the place
would come to talk to him,
because he was so colorful
and outrageous.
And he would give them
terrific quotes.
And they would come and listen
to him sound off on women and
baseball and beer
and whatever.
And he always provided good
copy-- much of it was
unprintable.
And long before Packers coach
Vince Lombardi uttered his
immortal quote--
what is it? "Winning isn't
everything-- it's the only
thing."
Well Gussie had put it much
more succinctly and
eloquently, I think.
And what he said was, "Being
second isn't worth shit,"
which didn't get printed
for years.
Because they couldn't print
that word in the papers.
So it was handed down as, "Being
second isn't worth
anything." Because they couldn't
even put in that he
said a bad word.
You couldn't indicate that
in the papers back then.
But that's how Gussie spoke.
There was one thing I mentioned
in the book where he
would do things like, he was
speaking about one long-time
employee who was retiring.
And he was going on and
on about the guy--
and people there, reporters
there--
and what a great employee
he was.
And then he stopped and he
said, of course, this has
nothing to do with his wife, who
was the biggest bitch that
ever happened.
That's Gussie.
Anyway, throughout the 1950s and
the 1960s, Gussie was the
king of beer.
It was undisputed.
He was the king of beer
of the planet.
He was the quintessential
beer baron.
He was friends with Harry Truman
and Lyndon Johnson.
He raised a ton of money
for Kennedy.
Hollywood celebrities would
come to his estate in St.
Louis, which was this enormous
gated thing that was named
Grant's Farm.
I don't know if anybody's
heard of it.
It's not really well known
outside of St. Louis.
But Grant's Farm was named that
because it used to belong
to Ulysses S Grant, who farmed
it unsuccessfully prior
to the Civil War.
Gussie's father bought it.
And they developed it into
this amazing thing.
And it features a 27 room French
Renaissance chateau on
300 wooded acres with a lake and
a stream and herds of deer
and elk and antelope and
buffalo, and even
giraffes and elephants.
And it's an amazing place.
And that's where he lived with
his third wife, who was this
beautiful blonde Swiss woman
named Gertrude Trudy, with
whom he had seven children.
All of them were born and
raised at Grant's Farm.
His father built the house.
And the house cost $350,000
in like 1900.
So that's a very expensive,
very impressive house.
There's a ballroom on
the third floor.
And in the main staircase right
off the ballroom-- in
the ballroom, there's room
for a full orchestra.
And the main staircase that goes
from the second floor and
down, the ceiling was perforated
so that the sound
of the orchestra could drift
down through the entire house.
Because you didn't have
speakers back then.
Anyway, they spent $350,000
on a house.
But they also--
his father spent almost
that much on a
barn for his animals.
And there's a thing--
I'll digress here.
There's this structure they
built at Grant's Farm that's
not like anything
I've ever seen.
And it may be unique
in America.
And they called it
the Bauernhof.
And it's basically
a barn that's the
size of a city block.
And it was made to look like the
structures in the medieval
Bavarian town of Rottenburg.
And it was modeled after what
was known as fortress farms.
And fortress farms were back in
the day when I guess there
was marauders and people
running around.
The farmers, they would build
a wall around everything.
And inside the wall, they
kept everything.
That's where the family lived.
That's where the working force,
the hands, lived.
That's where all the
animals were kept.
That's where all the equipment--
there was
a barn around it.
And this bauernhof
was spectacular.
And if you see it today,
it's hard to even take
a picture of it.
And it's hard to
even describe.
And it's not faux.
It's not like something
Disney does.
There's nothing faux about it.
It's the real deal.
It looks like Rottenburg.
And there's living quarters
there for the family, people
coming in from out of town
when Gussie was there.
Servants lived there.
There was a giant place for the
Clydesdales, and a huge
collection of these
antique carriages
that all of them collected.
The carriage house has
a room that-- the
ceiling might be 50 feet.
And there's animal heads all
over the place of animals that
have lived and died
on the estate.
And the center courtyard of this
place was big enough that
you could comfortably seat 1,000
people for dinner, which
happened a number of times.
They had a dinner for Harry
Truman once there.
And then one time, sales of beer
sort of dropped off in
St. Louis, and Gussie decided
he was going to
take care of that.
So he was going to throw a
party for anyone who had
anything to do with
selling his beer.
So he entertained 1,000 people
a night in the courtyard of
the Bauernhof for 11
straight nights.
And that's how big it is.
If you grow up in St. Louis, you
remember you probably took
a school field trip
to Grant's Farm.
Because at some point during
this thing when Gussie was
there living with the family,
somebody who was there at one
of his parties said, you know,
you really should-- this is so
marvelous for children.
You should open it
up to the public.
So he decided to do that.
He decided he would open up part
of it so that you could
come and you could tour the
animal enclosures, you could
see all the grounds
and all that.
You never could see the house.
The house is sort of off in
the distance, sort of
mysterious, so that they
kept their privacy.
But Gussie was this
attention whore.
He just loved to be the
center of attention.
He would just walk over from the
house, and he'd wade into
the crowds.
And he had a cockatoo named
Cocky, and pet monkeys and a
baby elephant.
He would do tricks like
the ring master.
And he just couldn't get enough
of the attention.
They would all gather around.
But it was this sort of magical
beer kingdom he
created that you remember
as a child.
Because you rode
a little tram.
And inner city kids could
literally reach
out and touch a buffalo.
And this was part of
the legacy of the
family in St. Louis.
And I remember it so
well going there.
And one of the most fascinating
days I spent in
the course of doing this
research on this book, I was
allowed to walk around Grant's
Farm and the house and the
Bauernhof by myself.
And it was just amazing
to see.
Because I had all these
childhood memories.
And it's still there.
But from the '50s and '60s and
into the '70s, it was Camelot.
It was Gussie and his wife Trudy
and the seven kids, and
the kids all worked
on the place.
And it was just spectacular.
And then, something happened
that sort of changed things
and led to a lot of stuff.
And I'll read my final passage
here about this.
"It was cold and raining
in St. Louis on
December 16, 1974.
The big house at Grant's Farm
was bustling with preparations
for the annual party celebrating
the feast of St.
Nicholas, the Old World patron
saint of children, and a
precursor to the modern
day Santa Claus.
Trudy always made a big deal out
of St. Nicholas Day, the
highlight of which was a visit
from an elaborately costumed
St. Nick who would suddenly
emerge from the trees and
enter the house carrying a bag
full of fruits, nuts, and
presents that he poured
out onto the floor and
distributed to kids.
The last thing St. Nick pulled
from the bag was a sapling
whipping switch, which he held
ominously in one hand while
relating all the naughty and
nice things each child had
done that year.
St. Nick was usually Trudy's
brother Willy, and the older
kids were sworn not to
tell the young ones."
I forgot to say something.
I have to set this up.
Bear with me a minute.
Right before this, the
Arab oil embargo hit.
And what happened was, because
America's supporting Israel
during the Yom Kippur War, the
oil exporting nations in the
Middle East stopped
selling us oil.
They just cut it off, and the
price of oil went totally off
the charts.
And it just wreaked havoc
on the economy.
And in California at that time,
you could only get gas
on every other day depending on
whether your license plate
ended in an even or
an odd number.
And the waits were like
an hour and a half.
And it hit business
really hard.
And everybody was
losing money.
And at Anheuser-Busch,
everything was
delivered on trucks.
So they were trying
to cut costs.
And so there was a meeting.
And in this meeting, Gussie
suggested that the patriotic
thing to do, and the good thing
to do for business, were
that all the executives were
going to get rid of their
company car.
Because we can't afford
that, and that's a
place to cut cost.
The problem was, he didn't
include himself in that, OK?
He had five cars, including
one for the family.
And they had a big heavy black
limousine that carried the
children to and from school.
So there was a big
fight about this.
And one of the executives
resigned over it.
And they never did have
to turn in their cars.
But they did trade out some of
the big cars, the company
cars, for smaller cars,
including the big sedan that
carried the children, which
they swapped out for a
Volkswagen van to save money.
That's where I forgot--
back to this.
"At 4:00 PM that afternoon on
Highway 244 just a few miles
from Grant's Farm, a tractor
trailer truck skidded off the
pavement and hurdled across
the grass median into the
opposite traffic lanes where it
struck a car, jackknifed,
and then collided head-on with
a Volkswagen van carrying the
two youngest Busch children--
11 year-old Andrew and
eight-year-old Christina--
on their way home from school.
The 50 foot flatbed rig cut
through the thin metal skin of
the van like a can opener,
severing the legs of the Busch
family's long-time chauffeur,
Nathan Mays.
Andrew Busch was thrown through
the front window of
the van and suffered serious
head injuries.
Christina, who was sitting
directly behind Mays, suffered
devastating head and
abdominal injuries.
Witnesses said the little girl
made it to the hospital alive
only because a car carrying five
nurses happened by the
accident, and they administered
to her and Andrew
until the ambulance arrived.
15-year-old Billy Busch was
waiting at his school for
Nathan to pick him up.
When the van didn't arrive by
5:00, he called home and was
told there'd been an accident
and someone else would come
for him shortly.
He was taken straight to St.
John's Mercy Hospital, where
much of the family had already
gathered in a waiting room.
'I remember thinking, this can't
be true,' Billy said of
the scene he'd encountered.
'Christina was in the ICU, and
mom told me they had all these
wires running in and out
of her and she couldn't
breath on her own.
They told me that Andrew was
going to be OK, but Nathan was
dead, which really upset
me, because I was
very close to him.
But I thought Cristina would get
better, because dad would
make it all right.
He would get the best doctors
and they would fix her.' The
most shocking thing to Billy was
the effect of the tragedy
on his father, who was collapsed
in a chair, sobbing
uncontrollably, unable to
take charge of anything.
'I'd ever seen dad like that,'
he said. 'It was like
everything had been taken out of
him.' Gussie doted on Tina,
his 11th child, born
when he was 67.
Blonde and blue-eyed like her
mother, she was the last of
the Mohicans, he liked to say.
He called her his little
honeybee and allowed her to
climb up on his lap at the
dinner table and take out his
false teeth and run
away with them.
He always danced with her at
family parties, and the sight
of the two of them, the oldest
and youngest of the Busch clan
delighting in one another,
always caused
people to stop and watch.
Now, they were both broken
beyond fixing.
'The doctors told us that
if they turned off the
ventilator, that Christina
probably would not survive.
And if she did, she would
probably be a vegetable
anyway,' recalled Adolphus IV.
'But mom and dad kept her on it
for 11 days to explore any
possible scenario.
They were looking for some
expert somewhere who might say
there was a chance.
There was no chance, however.
On December 17, the ventilator
finally was turned off, and
the baby of the Busch family
died, along with a big part of
her father, who would
never fully recover.
'I understand why dad felt so
bad,' said Billy. 'But I
thought he would come back.'
Instead, from what had been an
incredibly happy family where
everything went so wonderfully,
it all began to
fall apart."
Now, this struck me.
Because this is a story
about a business.
But it's also about a family.
And that's the one thing
that I really--
getting inside the family, I
was given access to some
members of the family.
They had never talked before.
They were like these cardboard
cut out rich people in most
people in St. Louis' mind.
And I got a chance to sort of
see what it was like inside
the family.
And they were a family.
And the kids would show at
dinner, and they had to have
their pajamas on and
the whole bit.
And it was very much
Ozzie and Harriet--
very rich Ozzie and Harriet.
But again, it was
still a family.
And this particular personal
incident caused
all sorts of things.
Everything turned on
this historically.
This causes a whole chain
of events to happen--
that I won't go into, because I
don't want to take away the
enjoyment of reading
the book--
that had to do with who
succeeded Gussie after this
was all over.
And everything sort
of turned on this.
And I won't go into it.
But it sort of was the end of
the magical beer kingdom that
he created there.
Now, he lived quite some time
after this, Gussie did.
He died at Grant's Farm in the
same bedroom his father had
died in 55 years before at the
ripe old age of 89 and married
to his fourth wife.
He died a very rich guy.
He was pretty much just as rich
as Adolphus when he died.
He controlled 35 million shares
of Anheuser-Busch,
which all passed to
family members.
And each of his 10 surviving
children got
big chunks of stock.
He had three different
families of children.
Depending on what family
you were in, you
got x amount of stock.
And the children who were born
and raised at Grant's
Farm got the most.
And they got 750,000
shares each.
So they never, ever
had to work again.
And some of them never did.
And the stock split a whole
bunch of time-- not a whole
bunch, but half a
dozen times--
after Gussie died.
And the only one of them
who never sold a
share of his stock--
he was determined.
He wasn't going to sell it,
because his dad never sold a
share in his whole life.
He had never sold a share.
The others all diversified.
But it was Billy Busch who
held onto every share.
And so when the company was
bought out in 2008 at $70 a
share, Billy Busch reaped
this huge fortune.
He made like $100 million.
And he decided that he didn't
like the idea-- he'd never
worked for the brewery.
But he decided that he didn't
like the idea that after 150
years of being part
of the community--
and Anheuser-Busch, you can't
walk four blocks in St. Louis
without Anheuser-Busch's name
on something that they
donated money to.
He didn't like the idea that
they weren't in the business,
and they weren't part of the
community anymore, and they
were just rich people.
So he took a chunk of his
inheritance, and he invested
in a beer company, which makes
the beer that you're drinking
right now, and that
Julie went to
considerable trouble to get.
Because it's only sold, by the
way, in Missouri and Illinois.
And it's the William K Busch
Brewing Company.
And it's the only beer that I
know of that's made according
to these ancient Bavarian laws
that says that beer can only
have four ingredients--
water, hops, yeast,
and barley--
that's it, for what
it's worth.
And so for me, it was like
a nice coda to the story.
The arc of the story from Gussie
in the magical beer
kingdom to the buyout, there's
a lot of tragedy in it, and a
lot of ugly stuff
that took place.
But this provided sort
of an upbeat ending.
Because 157 years after Adolphus
lands in St. Louis
and starts this dynasty, his
great grandson, William K
Billy Busch, is now the owner
of the smallest beer company
in St. Louis.
So it's sort of a full circle.
That's all I have in
terms of narrative.
But I'd be happy to answer
any questions you
have about beer, whatever.
I'm not a beer expert.
But feel free--
anyone out there, America.
AUDIENCE: What's your
favorite beer?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
My favorite beer?
Well, you know, I grew up on
Budweiser, drank a lot of
Budweiser in my time.
And then as I got older,
my love affair
with Budweiser waned.
And I played around with
foreign beers in green
bottles, cheated on
my first love.
And I tried everything.
But I kind of settled on--
I like Harp lager, which is a
lager made by Guinness, an
Irish lager of all things.
Microbrews and craft beers
tend to be sweet to me.
I like beers that have
bite to them.
Anheuser-Busch products
are kind of not
too exciting anymore.
They changed their formula
a lot over the years.
So Harp lager would
be my favorite.
I don't drink it anymore.
As I told someone earlier, I
decided a few years back that
it was time for me to get out
of the way and let the young
people have some.
But I had my share.
I didn't turn many away.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Well,
there's probably some guys
from Anheuser-Busch.
Everybody cashed out
for a lot of money.
Nobody in the family is.
They've all moved on.
And most of the executives
took buy-outs.
The guys who bought it--
Anheuser-Busch is not the
same company anymore.
InBev, which bought
Anheuser-Busch in 2008--
four years before, that
company did not exist.
It's basically an investment
portfolio of beer brands owned
by these three billionaires
from Brazil.
They made their money in banking
and because they own
the Walmart of Brazil.
And they bought a bunch
of old breweries.
And they sort of conglomerated
up.
So if you go there now, it's
inevitable what will happen.
They sort of run Grant's Farm,
and it's not quite as clean as
it used to be.
There's stuff on the floor.
You used to be able to eat off
the floors in the stable.
It's not like that anymore.
They don't care that much.
What happened with
Anheuser-Busch, at least in my
opinion, is that they were done
in by globalization and,
if you read it, drug
addiction.
That's what took it down.
And it's the same brand.
But they're now using malt
extracts, and they're using
all this stuff that the Busch
family would never have done.
The Busch family, they're
viewed now--
Anheuser-Busch--
by a lot of the craft beer world
as like, they were the
big behemoth of the enemy.
But they started out as
a craft beer company.
They were the littlest
beer company.
And they became Goliath.
But they definitely would not
use-- they used only natural
ingredients.
They wouldn't change, even
though it cost more.
All their competitors, like
Schlitz, which went down, and
all the others, they did all
these things to hurry up the
aging process.
But Gussie wouldn't
hear of it.
His father wouldn't hear
of it, no, no.
They aged that beer
30, 45 days.
And you had Schlitz, who was
their competitor, getting the
beer out in 10.
So they maintained quality.
And it's not going to be
like that anymore.
You may not like the beer, but
they did stand for that.
And whether or not you
liked the taste,
they maintained quality.
And that sort of changed.
And they're not as connected
to the--
if you think about it, since
I wrote the book--
and I may even have
that in there.
Yeah, I do have it in there.
It's this.
I got it.
The guys who took over, the
Brazilian guys, when they
bought Anheuser-Busch, in order
to buy it, they when
into debt, OK?
They borrowed all this money--
$50-some billion.
I don't know what it was.
And then, they had to
pay that down, OK?
So they had to cut costs.
And they negotiated contracts
that paid them bonuses based
on how much cost cutting
they did, not how
much beer they sold.
So they didn't sell
any more beer.
They didn't create any
more brand loyalty.
They didn't do any of that.
What they did was cut costs.
So they sold off this and
they sold off that.
And they got rid of 1,000 or
1,500 people in St. Louis.
And because they cut costs,
they qualified
for these huge bonuses.
And the one guy,
Carlos Brito--
when this came out, it
was sort of shocking.
He'd been there a year and a
half or two years and he
already qualified for a
$200 million bonus.
The group of executives who came
and took over totally got
bonuses worth $1.2 billion.
Now, $200 million was what
Gussie Busch was worth when he
left the company
after 50 years.
This guy came in and made $200
million because of cost
cutting in two years.
And so it's a different
sort of thing.
And it's sort of what's happened
in American business.
Back then, when the Busch
family ran it, they were
imperious, and they were
all this other stuff.
And there's all sorts of things
you could criticize.
But the company wasn't just
about trying to return the
highest possible rate of
return to investors.
It was about all kinds
of other stuff.
Yeah, they had to
do that, too.
But they were really
serious about jobs.
They were very proud of the fact
that when you worked for
Anheuser-Busch, you worked
for the gold
standard in St. Louis.
Everybody knew that if you
worked at Anheuser-Busch, you
got the best benefits, you had
the best medical care, you had
all the perks.
And that was what
they stood for--
we are a classy operation.
And they spent money.
Now, people who come in to buy
companies go, we don't need
that, we don't need that.
What about the way we're
feeding these horses?
Forget it, give them
some cheaper--
that's how they do it.
They cut costs and get
bonuses on it.
So Anheuser-Busch InBev will
continue to be a company for
the foreseeable future.
But it won't be the
same company.
It won't have that soul that
the Busch family gave it.
And they kind of went
the way of all
American business dynasties.
There aren't many left.
I think they may have been
the last great one.
So that's a long answer to
a short third question.
AUDIENCE: What about
the brew-pub thing?
Because you said that you can't
produce beer and also
own the establishment
that you sell.
So how does it work when you
own a brew-pub where you
actually have the brewing
equipment there, and then you
own the bar and--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: You
know, I don't know.
There must be some sort of--
he's asking about the--
out there.
AUDIENCE: It's changed in
the past [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: What?
AUDIENCE: It's changed
in the past 20 years.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: OK,
I don't know that.
He's asking about why you
can own a brew-pub and
sell your own beer.
I think it's probably there's
some rule that if you bake it
right there, you can sell
it right there, but
you can't sell it--
AUDIENCE: No, you need
a retail license.
If you have a retail license,
then you can
sell beer on the premises.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: But
Anheuser-Busch can't.
AUDIENCE: Because they
are [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Yeah, they
can't sell their beer on
their property.
They can give it away, but
they can't sell it.
They do give it away somewhat.
If you go through the
Anheuser-Busch plant in St.
Louis, you get some free
beer at the end--
another big attraction
in Missouri.
If you ever got to Missouri--
but you should go to Grant's
Farm and see the Bauernhof.
It's amazing.
Anybody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I've heard that
there are sometimes
[INAUDIBLE]
various variations on the
products so that you have more
choices but they're all
in the same stores.
And also they're trying to
cut into craft beer.
Do you think they have
a future [INAUDIBLE]?
Are they going to cut into
craft beer [INAUDIBLE]?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: He's
asking about the future of
Anheuser-Busch versus craft
beer and how they do them.
Yeah, I think they have been
doing that for years.
All the major beer
manufacturers, brewers, know
about craft beer and
how it's coming up.
And they're trying
to co-opt that.
And what they'll do
is, they'll buy.
If you're a craft brewer
and you're doing well,
Anheuser-Busch is going to knock
on your door and say,
we'd like to buy your company.
That's how big companies
always do it.
As far as all the products that
they have on the shelves
that all lead to the same thing,
well, that's kind of
what every food products
company does.
And they try and get more
and more shelf space.
Proctor and Gamble does that
with its soap products.
General Mills does that with
its cereal products.
You walk through the store, and
if you can take up 10 feet
of shelf space and whatever
they reach for is yours,
you're better off than
if you just have two.
So that's what they do.
But yeah, I think they
probably are
threatened by that.
Because your generation of
people has turned away from
traditional beers.
And it's probably hurting
them quite badly.
And I think they'll survive by
buying up, and there'll be
craft brewers that sell out
for a lot of money.
AUDIENCE: Sort of the reverse
question, but these things are
relevant [INAUDIBLE]?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Could
be, but that's not--
what happened with
Anheuser-Busch, the problem
was that they didn't
globalize.
Gussie Busch's son, August III,
who took over after him--
and that's a whole
big story there--
he pushed them to heights that
Gussie never imagined.
He made them the global power.
But they never responded to
companies like InBev, which
started buying up breweries
all over the country,
all over the world.
He didn't want to do that.
He wanted to keep getting
a bigger and bigger
share of the US market.
He thought they could
get 60%--
they were at 52%--
because the US market was
the most profitable.
And he didn't try--
he thought he would lose control
if he partnered up
with owning breweries
here and there.
And he always found a
reason not to do it.
And that was a short-sighted
thing.
So that all of a sudden, they
went from being the biggest
brewer to the second biggest
brewer to the third biggest.
And they lost power.
And that's sort of what led to--
all of a sudden, there
was somebody big enough to come
in and take them over.
That was unthinkable for
the previous 60 years.
There was nobody big enough
to come in and take over
Anheuser-Busch.
They were it.
So the craft brew thing,
I don't know if
that toppled them--
I don't think so.
And I don't think it'll
topple them now.
I think that it'll get
bigger and bigger.
But if you took all the craft
brewers in the country and put
their output up against the
two big beer companies,
they're not--
AUDIENCE: I'm not saying
to topple [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Yeah,
well it could be.
Yeah, I think that there's a big
future in craft brewing.
Because beer is now a thing
where you pair certain beers
with certain foods.
Nobody thought about that back
when they were coming up with
Bud Light, let me tell you.
Bud Light-- goes with anything,
because it doesn't
taste like anything.
Anyone else--
out there in America, anybody?
That's it?
Thanks for coming everybody.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]